on today's show we're going to talk to a
young woman whose friends are scared
of her fiance we're going to talk to a
wonderful young man who's trying to
bridge
cultural differences in his marriage
we're going to talk to a mom
whose sister donated an egg for their
new baby and yes
it's as complicated as it sounds stay
tuned
hey good folks i am john and this is the
dr john deloney show
it's a live show where we show up walk
alongside hurting people struggling
people
people frustrated with what's going on
we talk about anything
everything all of it whatever's going on
in your heart and your mind you are not
by yourself you are not alone
and i'm here to walk with you and there
are countless people mowing their yards
walking their dog doing the dishes and
just trying to ignore their family
listening to this podcast nodding tears
streaming down their face
because they identify with what's going
on in your heart and mind so give me a
call give me a shout
we are going to talk about family issues
we're going to be talking about
relationship challenges
we're going to be talking about loss
infidelity all of it
and we may talk about this i i want to
just be vulnerable here and tell you
about something that happened in my
house last night
and since my wife and especially my son
don't listen to this
um i even you know what even if they did
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a big deal
i think
being authentic is important last night
we put our kids to bed
and my wife went to um
go read and write something she does in
the evenings and
i heard my son's door open and so i got
my dad eye rolls ready
just what do you what do you want and he
came in
i tell you what man he just started
crying he just started crying
hard and we hugged for a long time and
didn't say much
and then he just said dad when is this
gonna stop
his school closed down so they're at
home through the the thanksgiving or
christmas break or for however long and
he's just coming off a two week
quarantine tweet back to school for one
day and now he's home and
he hadn't been able to go to church
hadn't been able to see his friends
his pet turtles several of them died
right in a row and just listening to the
tears of a young kid
just saying dad when does this stop and
me as his dad
having to tell him i don't know man i
know that i love you
i believe in my heart that god loves you
i know your mom loves you more than life
itself i know your sister loves you
but as to when all this hurt stops man i
don't know
and then i asked him to put his clothes
on and he got his clothes and a jacket
on and we just went for a walk outside
under the moonlight
and we live out in the woods and so
there's billions of stars
it was just a neat moment we spent
mostly in silence just walking
until finally he said man i'm really
tired i'd like to go to sleep and i
hugged him again and
we prayed and he went to bed but just
one of those holy moments between the
dad and the son
i don't have any comforting words other
than to say i'm here and i love you
and i promise this will pass someday
so if you're sitting there with your
loved ones and you're just wondering
they're wondering when does this stop i
don't know
but i know this we're in this together
and people only spin off and act bananas
act like jerks when they decide to and
so when we're all in this together we're
all walking step by step with one
another as somebody trips and falls
we're all there to pick each other up
it's like being in an old mosh pit right
somebody falls down everybody stops and
picks the other person up before you go
back to singing and dancing
and i hope you'll be there to pick me up
when i inevitably fall to
but be there for one another so
whatever's going on in your heart in
your home in your head i'm here to stand
with you give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
or the best way to get in touch with us
is to go to johndaloney.com
show and fill out the form tell me
what's going on in your
in your heart and your mind what's going
on in your home and we will get you here
on the show
all right let's go straight to the calls
we got a whole long list of of calls
today i'm excited
let's go to megan in asheville north
carolina good morning megan how are we
doing
morning john doing well how are you
outstanding
so how can i help this morning um
so recently this the beginning of this
year before everything went down
um my fiance was
diagnosed with ocd um and
decided to make a post about it like a
blog post on
um on social media i mean it basically
backfired
with my with a part of my family hmm so
the ocd that backfired i'm guessing then
it had to do more with
intrusive thoughts or looping thoughts
or does he have some ocd behaviors that
made people uncomfortable um it's the
it's the intrusive thoughts ah okay so
i've worked closely with some folks over
the years with this so
does he did he write some stuff that
scared people
yeah he sure did like what give us an
example what did he write
um so he talked about like having
thought of like
doing violent things to other people and
obviously like he would never do those
things
sure but just being so horrified of that
and just like
these huge like vivid images of doing
things
that are terrible to other people so why
did he feel the need to write that down
and and to put it out to the world there
um we
basically um been working on like
uh the two two of us together working on
like being truthful to who we are
and so he would that was his way of
being like i'm just gonna
let everyone know like what i've been
dealing with
um i mean maybe you've done maybe did it
in a little bit too public of a way
it's easier to see that now but in the
moment it was like i was
i was so proud of him you know gotcha so
um okay so he
posts this stuff and then then what
uh so i got a call from one of my
cousins
um and she was like hey like are you
okay like
and i was like yeah i'm totally fine and
she was like hey like if you if you need
anything just call me and tell me that
like you're going to talk about my
daughter's wedding
and and i was like no like and she
thought it was like that was an abusive
relationship oh she's setting up code
words for you
yeah okay no like i'm totally fine he's
great he wouldn't hurt a 5.
um anyway that conversation ended and
her daughter ended up having like things
that she didn't talk to me about
um and then i went to her and asked her
if i could bring him to the wedding
and she was like no i feel really
uncomfortable with him
okay and so that's hard to hear it's her
wedding
and so what'd you decide to do so i mean
we talked
and we were like you're gonna stay here
and i'm gonna go
and you know we'll i'll go be
be there for her and then i'll come back
and we'll we'll deal with things and i
called her even like and i told her like
how i was feeling about all of it and i
just let her know we were
we weren't gonna try to like make
anybody feel uncomfortable
which is really hard yeah that's hard it
is okay so
bring me to now how can i help with you
today so now
um we're trying to get married and i'm
dealing with
trying to figure out who my bridesmaids
are and she was always going to be
like my first choice you know and now
i'm like
i don't know if she wants like i want to
feel like i have people that are there
to support us
yeah and i don't
yeah and you feel like because she
expressed fear and concerns and drew
some boundaries early on that she
doesn't support him
doesn't support which means she doesn't
support you and you don't want her up
there representing this marriage
yeah so this just the thought of this is
bringing you to tears how come
um well i mean we've just always been so
close and she's always been like the
sister
that i never had yeah um
and like i think that i've decided that
i want to have her in the wedding
okay or at least want to give her that
option you know yeah
so with your permission i want to
reframe this for you is that cool
yeah okay yeah so
ocd and intrusive thoughts for the
person who's having them
is terrifying right yeah you've probably
watched him this guy that you love and
you're
you're about to marry you're about to
spend the rest of your life you've
probably
watched him be curled up in a ball by
some of this stuff right
yeah and you know him and you love him
and you've got
context with him and you see him every
day you interact with him every day you
know his
his voice inflections you not only know
him
intellectually but you know him really
spiritually right
yeah so much so you're gonna spend time
with him and my guess is you
probably know this other woman in a
similar fashion you've known her for
years she's somebody that you trust with
everything right is that fair yeah okay
so i want you to put your self in her
shoes
and somebody who she loves almost more
than life itself which is you
is in love with a guy who posts online
his uncontrolled fantasies uncontrolled
dreams
about feeling violent fantasies about
murdering people about killing loved
ones
about seeing blood every whatever
whatever
violent imagery he put out there and she
at
from that point forward because she
loves you and because she cares about
you
has one goal in mind and that is to make
sure you're safe
and she probably did that with all the
only tools she had which is to call you
directly good friend for her
and then she's giving you code words
she's trying to help out here
and you have to walk her back and once
you walk her back once her default
setting
which is i want to make sure megan's
okay once you convinced her of that
then she has a responsibility to
everybody else in her in her wedding
party she got a responsibility to
herself
and she did a brave bold thing i'm not
saying it's right
i'm not saying it's nuanced and
understanding of people with ocd who
would never commit these acts but still
they're plagued by these haunting
recurring recurring you know vivid
imaginative dreams
yeah can i can i stop you sorry of
course that was her actually her mother
who did that
oh her mom did okay she didn't actually
talk to me at all about it until
oh okay okay so her mom got involved
all right so she's not as brave and cool
as i thought but but
all that to say is this give people the
benefit of the doubt
yeah what you if you were to objectively
go back and reread what he wrote i bet
it's scary isn't it
it's hard for me to say because i have
gone back and read it and i
and i don't i don't think it's scary
give me an example
um like well i mean he put in the post
like no if
like these are going to be scary like
sort of
vivid images and he like didn't really
say but give me an example
give me give me an example of
something that he said yep um
he just said something general like i
have like
thoughts of like violently hurting other
people that is enough right there for me
to say
ah probably not i want you on my kids
right that's
yeah that's fair and every time somebody
does something public right there's a
mass shooting or a map they go back and
they
look at their writings at their post and
they all go
whoa we should have seen that coming
right yeah now
what those incidents don't don't tell
the
they don't tell the full story because
there's a bunch of other people who
write things like that that write
harsh poetry or they write very vivid
violent things
and they're never going to hurt anybody
but the meta narrative is
if you look back and see some of that
stuff man you could see the video post
and the blog post and the need to tell
everybody they were
they were planting seeds here right and
so all that to say is this whether it's
your friend whether it's your friend's
mom
whoever it is give them benefit of the
doubt
for what happened in the past and now
you're bringing yourself to here
if you don't want her in your wedding
then don't have her in your wedding let
that fantasy go
if you do want her in the wedding invite
her to be in your wedding
right yeah
i think overthinking it and over
traumatizing yourself over this decision
is gonna cause you way more pain than
just making a call and moving on
yeah what does he think about it
um surely he understands that
that people are going to react adversely
to this
he actually didn't at first like i was
trying to like tell him what you were
telling me
um and he actually had a bigger problem
with it because it was like
he was he felt rejected which is fair
like
he said he was gonna he's dreaming about
hurting people and yes people
then went to cover their children yes
that's fair
right now with some understanding of
somebody with his
um with his mental health challenges
yeah i mean that's a whole different
conversation but the average person is
never going to know that
which is why going all the way back to
what to our original like my first
question why did he post this
there is something incredibly perverse
that's that's come upon all of us in the
last decade which is this
this idea of radical integrity and
radical honesty
and which is important and critical and
then going over the edge which is i'm
just going to put every
thought every year every everything
right so we'll talk to young couples who
are like i just want to be me bro and i
just want to
make sure my wife knows everything and
then you see somebody attractive at the
mall
and they're like hey babe she's super
super hot and i'm kind of having
shut up dude what are you doing right
there's a difference between being
radical honesty and being an idiot
right and there's a difference between
being
completely 100 open and
spewing every thought or every um
challenge out into the world with no
context no relationship no understanding
right
yeah and so again if he was on the phone
i would really want to dig in
what compelled you to not be honest with
you
to not be just honest with a therapist
but to post something to the world
like what was to be gained by that but
that's a whole other conversation that's
not why you called me
i think you just need to make a decision
and be totally at peace because here's
one
important thing with a period at the end
of it okay
this is your wedding and you can have
whoever you want there
or not have you ever you want there and
nobody gets a vote but you
yeah that's it and that might mean that
you've got to re-reimagine this fantasy
that you had about your wedding it's 20
20
all of us are reimagining every weird
thing we had planned anyway
right or you can forgive your friend
for loving you and trying to care about
you and the only way she knew how
and for reading things that are
disturbing they just are
um that was stripped of context and in
any sort of relationship
and you can bring her into the fold and
she may not want to and that still
doesn't mean that she doesn't love you
and shouldn't be at your wedding yeah
but yeah i think you're beating yourself
up unnecessarily i think
letting this one ride making a call and
then just going on with it
i think it's going to be a whoo
relief for your soul
just do it just do it megan
and again
be graceful with people who get
confronted with violence get confronted
with imagery get confronted with
the other side of mental health
challenges you won't find a bigger
advocate than me
that's why that's my spend my life doing
that but there's another side to it
which is also
i fully 100 understand when people are
caught off guard by it
when their first instinct is to recoil
that's natural and that's
fair and radical honesty has its place
but it doesn't have its place all over
unsuspecting people who didn't ask for
it
who didn't invite themselves into that
conversation
but i do appreciate you loving him and i
do appreciate you being a person of
character trying to think through what's
the right thing to do here
but don't overthink it you've got it
your wedding your choice your decision
roll with it you've got this all right
let's go to jack in los angeles
my brother jack how are we doing this
morning hey good doctor john how are you
doing
outstanding brother how are we doing um
pretty good so i'm i'm calling you
because
i'm having an issue with i guess
conflict resolution
with my in-laws and they come from a
very different
cultural uh background and have
different behavior
norms than than the family i grew up
with so i'd like to get your perspective
on it
very cool man well thanks for the trust
there so what what two cultures are we
bringing together
here so i'm a white midwestern
um guy uh moved to los angeles
um but you know we're raised very kind
of straight ahead you know be direct
tell it like it is
and um my wonderful wife and her family
are from korea they've lived here for 20
years
you know so they're integrated um into
american culture but they also carry
you know these these norms where they
don't directly approach conflict the
same way that i do
and they have found that the way that i
do it can be um
pretty abrasive there you go i love
pretty harsh yeah
hey so first off i want to just high
five you brother from nashville to los
angeles thank you for being a guy who
loves his wife enough
to try to go down the the
hospitality route instead of just being
an egotistical brash idiotic
husband i applaud you brother and
it's going to take more work and it's
going to take some compromise on your
part in some reimagination learning some
new language but dude good for you man
if more people were like you would have
less of the nonsense we've got these
days so good for you
all right so give me a scenario
where you want to learn how you can
better address the situation
okay sure so the most recent one uh was
um that they come over to our house a
lot um they
sometimes stay pretty late and it's you
know past the kids bedtime i've got
small we've got small kids
um and i'd like to tell them that it's
time to go
um but if i say things like that then
they get offended and they don't want to
come back and visit
and then my wife says uh don't be that
direct with them
just just let me tell them instead but
to me i feel like
i need to step in when it's like you
know 9 9 30 at night and
it's pretty late for the kids so will
she not step in is she asking you
to do something that you've seen her
repeatedly not do or does she have a way
that she can do it
more gracefully that that um lets
her parents retain their dignity and
their cultural respect
and still gets the meets everybody's
needs which is we gotta get those kids
to bed all right um well she can do it
with
with grace but it has to kind of be a
pre-planned thing
it can't be something in the moment um
where
you know gosh we look at the clock and
we realize oh my gosh it's nine o'clock
right it has to be something where
i talked with her ahead of time and say
okay you know they're coming over
great let's just tell them it's time to
you know go around eight o'clock
and so why why don't we just do that my
wife has actually brought that to
my life over the last few years and it
has been incredible
now when we've got people coming over to
the house we just tell them
hey we're wrapping up tonight at 7 7 30.
we gotta get the kids to bed
and everybody drops their shoulders
they're like okay cool
it's just a gift right now of course we
there's
the occasion when everybody runs past it
we're having some great conversation
everyone's laughing carrying on and
suddenly it's 9 30 or 10 that happens
right
but it's rare especially doesn't happen
with in-laws
so do you not like pre-planning or do
you really at the root
you don't like not being able to say
what you want to say in your own house
um well the latter's definitely part of
it um
and that's probably an ego thing there
and um
i i think i like to be a planner but i
think it just takes me by surprise
when you know like when they come and
they don't just realize that
it's time to leave you know when it's
like nine o'clock what happens if you
just start getting the kids ready for
bed
um i kind of feel like that
even would cause a conflict too like
whoa what are you
doing with the kids like we're we're
hanging out um
you know i think that would even be
considered as like i'm not
playing nice with the family gotcha so
here's here's the easy this may be the
easiest call i've ever taken on this
show that's not true there was one a few
weeks ago that was super easy
um it's just this simple
you can choose to
default to hospitality and harmony in
your home which means
being um submissive to
your in-laws culture to the way they
communicate with one another
the way that they can retain dignity and
respect in their
home and in their marriage or you can
say this is my freaking house i can do
whatever i want
that's your two choices if it's me i'm
gonna do everything i can to be more
respectful which means
in your situation we're probably gonna
have to plan we're probably gonna have
to be
pretty pretty dogmatic about saying hey
we're done at seven o'clock we gotta get
those kids in bed
and then we're gonna roll from there i
would also recommend
having a regular regular
tea time or coffee time or meal time
with your father-in-law
do you all just go hang out you too
okay do you have you ever done that oh
do we yeah um
yeah actually yes and we get along
really great yeah so that would be
that would be super fun for both of us
so have you ever asked him
to teach you about his culture have you
ever asked him to say
hey i'm so intrigued i love your
daughter i want to learn more about this
how do i say this or how does somebody
express this and give him an opportunity
just to be the teacher how does that go
it goes really well yeah yeah we get
along really well and i think
me he and i connect um better than i
connect with
like the um the women in his family
outside of my wife um i think just does
guys and just we have
sort of similar personalities so yeah i
think i think the door is always open
there to connect with him more very cool
i think that would be i'd go a long way
and one final question before i let you
go
when you say if you come in and say hey
it's nine o'clock guys i'm so sorry but
i gotta get these kids to bed
and you grab the kids you tell them to
do the
hugs and kisses make the rounds and then
we're gonna take them off to bed
and somebody sounds like your
mother-in-law says
that's so offensive i'm never we're
never coming back here again
like this is embarrassing for us we've
overstayed our welcome now we feel
ashamed
and we committed a hospitality violation
and i'm embarrassed i'm not coming back
do they actually come back
it takes a few weeks um but they do and
and yeah but that conversation doesn't
happen in the moment it happens like
you know on group chat afterwards that
i'm not on
so i hear about it from my wife but yeah
so i i kind of have to show
you know show that i'm sorry that i hurt
the feelings a little bit invite them
over more
and then you know usually in a few weeks
it usually gets better
gotcha and so yeah i think letting your
wife
be a the powerhouse grown woman that she
is
and if she says i can contribute to this
communication
and help honor my parents that's awesome
and if you offline can begin to deepen
your relationship with your
father-in-law
if you could do it with your
mother-in-law if you just had regular
you know
coffee with your mother-in-law once a
month once every few weeks and
slowly all continue to learn and grow
and um
love each other and then yeah you put
your ego in a drawer when you're dealing
with your in-laws
you be respectful and hospitable and you
just plan
again man those seem like really small
things to honor somebody those seem like
really small things to
to continue to create family um
peace right and then you are free to
raise your kids
in combination with your wife as best
you all see fit
as best as y'all see fit but honoring
your in-laws is such a gift
and i know it's that's not me bro
i know man i know people are listening
to this being like i wouldn't do that i
would tell them
well then you're an idiot and jack
you're a good human being man
good for you for trying to be hospitable
um man you've made my whole day better
brother and it started off not too great
today
but you have turned it around for me man
so i'm grateful for you
all right let's go to marie in chicago
illinois
marie good morning how are we doing
doing all right thank you for talking to
me no thank you for calling how can i
help
okay so um i'm looking for some guidance
on how to explain better to my husband
why
myself and my sister who happens to be
on
our daughter's egg donor that we feel
it's important that we share the
information about how she was conceived
with our children
we have a son that's a little bit older
and the loved ones
now before it becomes like a thing so we
can kind of control it
oh honey you can't see my face right now
but
whoa so your sister is your egg donor
she was yes does she live by you guys
uh she's about an hour away we we're
pretty close wow
okay there's a lot
and you've probably held your daughter
she's only she's gonna be three in
january so okay that's not really our
issue right now
well she super is and i'll tell you i'll
walk you through it
um okay so
oh man there's a lot here
and i know it feels like there's just
one thing or two things but i promise
you there's a lot here
wowzers okay so
what was the original agreement here
and what and and i want to i want to
talk in um
i want to talk in adoption terms so was
this a
quote-unquote closed adoption did your
sister give you an egg legally
that she terminated rights to that is
completely yours and y'all came up with
some sort of
agreement i guess um you and her and
your husband is that what happened
yes there is like legal paperwork and
everything okay
so she has terminated any and all claim
to this egg
yes and what was the agreement did you
all shake hands and say we're going to
keep this quiet forever
um yeah pretty much um going into it
obviously not
knowing what was really yeah i guess
everything's going to explode on us yes
um
okay and i know you didn't think you're
gonna get this response from me
this is a this is a messy one so
one year goes by two years go by and now
you're at three years
and so then who brings up what
conversation tell me where we're at
um okay so my sister is um
more like she's been kind of keeping her
thoughts to herself
and so we've been working through stuff
me and her and it finally
this all just kind of came out about a
year ago
and then i want to know exactly how that
came out
um she finally said to me
i just feel like a donor
i don't feel like you thought about me
or you think about me or
and she doesn't want like any rights or
anything like that
these are just conversations like her
and i have had but she was feeling hurt
but going into it she did say i never
want to speak about this again
and she's five years younger than me
yeah so
so here's you have a 10 year old
biological
child i have a biological son
and but she doesn't have any children
okay wow
okay so
oh man so here's here i'm just gonna be
as honest as as i can is that cool
yeah it's probably more than you're
asking for so
the first thing that you're gonna have
to put down put aside
is any sort of fantasy that this is
gonna be a smooth sale for the next
rest of your life okay yeah because
here's what's gonna happen
here's what's already happening is
your sister your aunt
is watching a mini-me version of herself
grow
up and
slo initially it's i'm going to do this
because it's an awesome gift i can give
to my sister
what a blessing i don't have any kids of
my own i got
an egg despair here you go i'm going to
sign all the paperwork i don't even talk
about this again
right and then she sees somebody that
looks just like her
and then she sees somebody that responds
or curls her lip or moves her eyebrow
just like her
and then suddenly i don't want anything
to do with this but
i feel like you're leaving me out i
don't want to do anything but
i'm just the donor here and suddenly
this regret this harshness this uh and
then it's
well of course we're gonna have to tell
this baby right and i know we all agreed
we
y'all signed some papers of some sort
about not saying anything or jaw just
all high-five each other on the way out
in the parking lot and say
no they make you legally sign papers
that's right man
and so now you've got somebody in your
house
that probably looks like your husband
and acts like you and your husband
and looks a lot like your little sister
and i'm just guessing here
and now you're recognizing
secrets destroy families so you have to
tell her
of course you have to tell her of course
right it's not a matter of if it's when
now
that's dna and everything but
you've got a husband now who agreed to
this whole thing
under another set of circumstances
however screwed up those circumstances
were
and now he feels like his world's
getting turned upside down because the
people who agreed to do this not like
change yes well it's not that but
he he it's not a matter of change it's a
matter of
hey i mean it doesn't like change of
plans
yeah but this is bigger than just a
change this is bigger than a change of
plans
this is a complete uprooting of
everything he thought was gonna be
happening moving forward now i'll be the
first to tell you what he thought was
gonna happen
was way wrong but this is not just like
hey i thought we were gonna go eat at
red lobster and now we're going to
burger king
this is not that right right yes
yes because here's here if he's wise
here's what he's looking at down the
road
he's looking at a series of
conversations
over the next 20 years explaining this
which isn't bad kids are resilient kids
get things
over time he'll get this or over time
your daughter will pick this stuff up
and she'll
this will be the only world she knows
right and this is great
right that's why we want to kind of make
it normal now right
but something we planned to do which we
did but
yeah of course you planned it you didn't
think it through though
because now
your husband is going to watch this
young woman grow up in your home that
looks a lot like your sister
and at the first sign of trouble
10 to 13 in that range when she knows
she's gonna say something like well
you're not even my mom
and you are gonna melt and
her your sister my guess is will be
there to just to help out
right possibly
she's gonna have to be an iron-clad
woman
she's gonna have to be stronger than me
because i tell you what man if i saw
somebody
that shared my dna running around i'm
always gonna have one eye looking over
there to make sure they're doing okay
and if they fall down i'm gonna be there
too it would be a very
extraordinary person who could be that
close to a situation and that
differentiated from it
right yeah
and so is your sister gonna try to
co-parent says begin to
slowly start leaning in here no
no we not like in the relation
relationship end of it because she feels
like
i mean she's talking to somebody about
this too but she feels like
she has the same relationship with her
that she does with
my son because she doesn't even really
technically want children
right now i know but doesn't know if she
wants them
right and so what she's getting to do is
to
presumably have the best of both worlds
right
well yeah they just send them home
that's right she got to contribute
to the making of a child you or her mom
make no mistake
right you are her mom through and
through and through
but your sister got to contribute see
what it looks like
see somebody who looks like her grow up
and not have to deal with it
right so she's getting she's trying to
play both sides here
but i also understand man what a gift a
sister to a sister right
and i don't i don't want to think she
was an evil person at all
yeah it's a beautiful gift um
well and i think with him it's just it's
like
i don't want this to blow up and be like
it's this big secret
that she finds out later right and i
think he's more worried about like what
people he's we've talked very little
about it because it blows up very
quickly yeah
um but it's like he's he's
i think he's worried that somebody he
always worries about what people think
like they're gonna be like well her real
mom
so i think it's more about like he
hasn't thought in the future part yet
but
his initial like he comes from a very
traditional family and they know very
little about our ivf
even story yeah so so like we didn't
share that because it was just easier
not to
because he would get questioned and it
was
we didn't know answers then so
yeah so so worried i think about what
people are going to think
he's drowning in secrets right now
yeah i mean it was a it was i mean our
closest family like i have
all my cousins and aunts and uncles are
all right here in our same town
so like it's gonna be there's only
probably a handful of people that
actually do know
yeah so be really graceful with him
okay this is a big deal and
if he doesn't have the tools he clearly
doesn't and this isn't a knock on him
this is just a
like i i don't know how to lay tile in a
kitchen
he does not have the tools to walk
through his relationship challenges
to walk through his heartbreak over
fertility stuff he doesn't have any of
that those tools
and so what he's done is he's just kept
everything zipped up
and yeah he's losing some like
resentment
because at first we weren't going to do
ivf
then we weren't going to do we were
going to do our ui then we did ivf then
we were gonna only do one round
then if it didn't work it didn't work
right and then suddenly you find
yourself
pushing it yeah you find yourself fifty
thousand dollars in the hole and what's
sixty thousand
what's seventy thousand right and now
you're right it was just that one more
step i just wanted my son
to have a sibling a person right that
was my goal
and she stepped up she did
she did and i'm not here to judge that
process
right what i am here to judge is y'all
didn't think it through all the way
and you have to have a book on that
there's not there's not right
no and so when you find yourself in a
situation with two people that you love
here's what i'm worried about is
happening to you you're gonna lose your
husband over this deal you're gonna lose
your sister over this deal
because you're not talking with one
another you're not all in the same room
with one another
and you guys have to have hard
conversations all three of you together
and my guess is you're gonna have to
start with your husband
and you're gonna have to start with a
marriage counselor
tomorrow because i can't imagine
what he's trying to navigate in his head
with the limited tools he's got
right okay and i can't imagine
him feeling like his whole world is
unwinding and he may not know that the
right thing to do is to tell his little
girl
and he may not know that the right thing
to do is to not keep secrets from your
ten-year-old son
obviously tell people age-appropriate
things one of my
um great friends um it's a husband and
wife
team of therapists are incredible but
they said when you're having hard
conversations with kids
do building blocks of truth so the next
truth sits on top of that previous truth
so they don't have to unlearn and
relearn something new
your three-year-old your 10 year old
probably is not going to fully
understand sperm and egg
and implementation are implants and
they're not going to get all that right
no um they do understand
a little baby takes apart from a boy and
part from a girl
and we had to go see a special doctor to
help out they get that truth which he
he knows that we went to like special
doctors because he was there with me a
lot but
yes that was three years ago he didn't
comprehend
that's right that's right so but your
husband may not know that truth
is the best way here and so i'm just
telling you be graceful with him
and as y'all figure this out again don't
use language
please don't use language like he just
doesn't like change this is not just
slight change
right this is what i'm calling a
systemic overhaul
and then you're gonna have to be
graceful with your sister because she's
gonna watch a spitting
mirror image of herself walking around
and she signed a piece of paper that she
didn't fully understand what she was
signing
agreed and you're gonna have to be extra
graceful
with your daughter when she says things
like you're not my mommy because you
know you are
right and you're gonna have to be oh
yeah extra graceful with your sister
when she says
well that kid's 50 mine and you can
gently say
she's not she's got 50
she's got 25 dna from her dad and 25
nurture and she's got 25 of your her dna
and you're giving her the other 25 so
she's actually 75 year old 25
her you can use that kind of math right
other than 50 50.
yeah but math answers never solve the
hole in her heart that she's gonna have
walking watching her little girl walk
around and so you're gonna
end up with a much tighter relationship
with your sister if y'all will be honest
with one another
or an absolute disaster right which i
think we're working towards that i think
we've come
it was pretty bad for a year or two and
i think we're
really coming together but i don't want
it to be like me and her against him
yeah it can't be it's got to be the
you've got to start with him
yeah start with him and root yourself in
right
so here's my meta secrets destroy
families you're going to have to create
a plan to systematically tell your kids
right very gently over a long period of
time
over and over and normalize it this is
their world
right and right that's what we have we
want to do normalize it
that's what you want to do now what he
wants to do
right correct and so when he feels like
he's being ganged up on
by somebody who just donated an egg
suddenly it feels like he's got two
wives
and he's got two mothers and he's got
two people co-parenting
do you see what i'm saying she doesn't
get a vote at this point she's out
right he gets a vote and so you want to
tell your kids
you want to improve your relationship
with him and quite honestly you
i'm just speaking for you here but my
guess is you love that man
and you want him to be able to finally
drop his shoulders and just be who he
truly is
and be a vulnerable guy that was a part
of a relationship that struggled with
fertility challenges
that he went to bed heartbroken and
lonely sometimes
and then he was able to have an
incredible opportunity to
somebody reached up and donated an egg
and now he's got a beautiful daughter
that he loves
and if people are going to say what
they're going to say they're going to
say what they're going to say right but
he needs to learn the tools to be able
to put that kind of nonsense down
but at the end of the day
wow you got to start from square one
with him and you got to be graceful with
him because you are changing the rules
you all should have thought this through
it it's over you're here now
and now you've got a very messy
situation moving forward that can only
be cured
only be helped with grace and over
communication
and honesty with one another moving
forward he's gonna have to get to a
place where he knows
secrets destroy families it destroys
children it destroys marriages
that's not an option but also you
ganging up on him with your sister
isn't an option either so start with him
start with yourself and we'll slowly
work and get there
your daughter's three so you got some
time on this deal
um and letting your son know whenever
y'all do sit down and start to have
these conversations
hey this we didn't have a playbook on
this one and so we're learning
and we probably made some mistakes we
probably did some things wonderful
at the end of the day we have a you have
a beautiful sister
that we love who lives in our house and
i'm the mom and he's the dad
and we're figuring out as we go and we
love both of you so so much
and start from there but
all of this starts on a a new foundation
of
i love my husband and we're in this
together
we're in this together sister
will come along later but right now
we're in this together
marie let me know how those
conversations go if your husband wants
to give me a call i'd love to talk to
him too i'd love to get his perspective
on this this is such a unique case but
it's such a messy situation too
um have him give me a call otherwise
keep me updated on how things are going
and
i look forward to hearing from you soon
we'll be thinking about you
but start with him and start with a good
marriage counselor asap
all right let's run out to aaron in
battle creek michigan my brother aaron
how are we doing
i'm good dr john how are you this
morning i am blessed and doing all right
how can i help you man wonderful well i
work for a
uh company that uh started back in the
80s
on biblical principles and um
here in recent days the founder of the
company and his sons have
sold their stock they've retired and an
executive board has kind of taken over
and they're headed in a direction that
really doesn't
line up with some of those biblical
principles and i've spoken to our
location manager about that he was
he was a pastor as well as i was at one
time too
and those concerns that i had
just kind of got blown off and the
direction that i see the company going
just doesn't it doesn't set well with me
and there's some injustices and some
other little things that have come in
and
i i kind of want to know how do i handle
this how do i deal with this because i
like my job i like what i do
but i want to know how to how to walk
through this with with grace and and
be able to do my job and do it well
uh man that's a lot there so um very
quickly give me one or two things define
quote unquote biblical values what is
that what does that mean
um you know uh for one treating treating
your customers the way that uh the way
that you would
want to be treated yourself you know in
in the biblical sense of of treating
people and
uh being a servant leader um just much
like jesus was you know a servant leader
and
um not seeing i'm not seeing some of
those things i'm seeing you know our
customers kind of being blown off
now that we're getting bigger and i've
seen some some processes
in place there's some favoritism and
things that are that's going on and
and i'm not the only one that sees it
but um i just i want to know that you
know
now that i've shared uh my perspective
and and
the biblical principles um how do i deal
with this you know i mean
and going on without getting angry
without you know getting sideways with
with the powers that be so to speak yeah
i mean it sounds like you've got a
couple of options number one
you did the noble and integris thing and
you had a concern
and you took it to your supervisor took
it to your boss you took it to the
person you've got a problem with
sure right and they blew you off
right and i'll say this with all due
respect but they're the boss
and however poor leadership that is
they're the boss
right okay and it is what it is
and so now you've got a decision to make
you love your job
but your job is beginning to violate
your values
right and you can ask yourself are those
values things that you can control
meaning can you continue to treat
customers the way they deserve to be
treated
not because they're customers but just
because there's a basic decency
and human respect that you have for
other people right
right um can you control that
can you um control the fact that we're
gonna have good books we're not gonna
cook the books we're not gonna
fudge numbers here we're not are those
things things you can control
or is the values of the organization
what at such that you got to leave
okay and if a lot of times i hear
these kind of conversations about
injustices and things aren't fair
are people getting paid differently let
me ask you that question
uh yeah absolutely yeah that's that's
usually the chief injustice right and
and
and a lot of it is is people who have a
lot less experience
yeah a lot less time um and and that
that one actually does affect me
directly sure so
here's the thing um here's my here's my
philosophy on this
and and you people can send me all kinds
of mean hate mail but here's my
philosophy
whenever i agreed to come work here for
dave ramsey
literally dave and i sat in a meeting
with a couple other people and we shook
hands
on a salary it was fair
it was more than fair it worked for me
and my family
and we shook hands if i then walked
downstairs
and saw rachel cruz and chris hogan and
said hey what do you guys make and it
was triple what i just said
that would not be any injustice at all
and here's why
because we shook hands on it i agreed to
it you agree to it
and nobody tricked me the injustice
would be if dave and i shook hands and
then he paid me half
then i would have a claim for injustice
but if suddenly he decides i want to
move the company in this direction
with people who have this level of
expertise this level of degree
we've been doing things like this for a
long time
and over time i'm going to phase out the
way we're doing it we're going to start
doing it this way
and these folks have a new type of
expertise
and i'm going to pay them this much
because that's what the market demands
for this particular credential and this
master's degree or whatever
then that's not an injustice to me it
might piss me off
i might think well that's a box of farts
i want to be making that much money
but it's not an injustice does that make
sense
yeah i think so a little dead and you
know there's there's also
different departments you know involved
company-wide you know it's not just
one big department you know there are
people in other other departments you
know as far as that goes and so
right i work in one department and some
of these guys you know work in
other departments and as i looked at
things i thought well dude you haven't
even been here as long as i have and
i've got more experience than you do and
you know so those were the things that
came to my mind
as i was walking through some of these
things and i and like i said that's just
one piece of the puzzle that's right but
it is a piece of the puzzle that really
bugs me that's right
so hey here's the deal aaron i'll make
it real simple
you can put those bricks down and choose
to have a great life
or you can carry that stuff around and
it's just going to weigh you down
because it's not going to change
leadership
right it's not going to suddenly add
dollars to your paycheck right
it's not going to suddenly someone's not
going to be like you know what we
haven't done
we haven't recognized aaron's x number
of years of expertise in this particular
thing
they're just not going to do that right
and so any action you take outside
of that is you consciously choosing to
have less joy in your life
sure that's it and i hate that it's that
simple or dude quit
go work somewhere else that's going to
value your expertise right
and that's that's that's putting the
ball in your court
the one thing the one injustice here
that can be done
is if you choose to go to work every day
and poison the environment
right if you choose to have offline
conversations with other dudes who've
been there a long time
other men and women who've been working
their butts off and they're not making
as much as these young kids in that
department
that's injustice that's unfair
right because at the end of the day you
shook hands on a deal
and if you can go get a better deal down
the street go get it man
go get it or if you can choose to
put down these bricks of
what about them what about them and just
accept
we shook hands he says gonna pay me 70
000 bucks a year
that was a great deal for me and my
family until i found out he was paying
her 150 grand
she maybe she negotiated better maybe
she's got a graduate degree maybe he's
got plans or she's got
plans to take this company in a totally
different direction
at the end of the day getting inside
people's heads and trying to figure that
stuff out is just going to weigh you
down
values in a company is a big deal to me
if i feel like
values wise we are dishonoring people we
are not telling the truth
i will walk out the door and i live my
life in a way
where i don't owe people money where my
wife and i live pretty frugally
i drive an 06 truck um
somebody door dinged me the other day
and they were just like their face lost
all the color and i just started
laughing
and i was like dude that's why i drive
an 06 truck that's just one less thing
for me to worry about right
i live my life in a way so that i can
always
be attached to my values
and that's just a way we've chosen to
live and
um that's why i work at a values-based
company that loves people
whose core philosophy is if we help
enough people the money part takes care
of itself
but we're going to help people and help
people and help people and that's where
we're going to default to so
aaron i get the pain here and i want to
be dismissive of you brother and i
appreciate the call
i understand what it feels like to be in
a room and not feel like you're being
valued i've been there
i understand what it's like to be making
a certain dollar amount and they hire a
new kid and they're making more than you
i've been there
but i also understand the futility of
trying to
grasp and hold on to things that you
can't control
just look at the things you can control
which are your attitude
which is how hard you're going to work
and your set of values
and anything that falls outside of those
three things set them down
and if you can't reconcile those three
things go get another job man
you're a good guy you work hard you put
the time in
go find someone that will value you i
really appreciate your call brother
thanks to everybody who called i'm going
to leave us today
with a classic the song of the day is a
classic from 1988
the self-titled record b
squared they called him mr bobby brown
writing the classic my prerogative bobby
writes
everybody's talking all this stuff about
me why don't they just let me live
tell me why i don't need permission to
make my own decisions
oh that's my prerogative it's my
prerogative
it's the way that i want to live i can
do just what i feel
no one can tell me what to do because
what i'm doing i'm doing for you
it's my prerogative bobby you should
call my friend aaron and let him know
it's your prerogative too this has been
the dr john deloney show